[Música]
y llegó el momento de conocer que nos
tiene hoy revista de Prince y por ellos
saludo en el estudio a mi compañera
Marta Moya Marta muy buenos días Hola
Andrés Buenos días Marta vamos a abrir
esta esta revista de prensa alrededor
del juicio político que empieza hoy en
Ecuador contra el presidente Guillermo
lasso es la segunda vez que la asamblea
legislativa Busca su destitución y esto
ocupa titulares tanto a nivel local
regional y hasta internacional vamos a
empezar entonces con lo que dice el
universo en Guayaquil sí Andrés el
universo repasa un poco Cuáles son las
causas por las que se va a enjuiciar
políticamente a Guillermo lasso al
presidente ecuatoriano recuerda este
artículo que este martes a las 10 de la
mañana hora local va a dar comienzo el
juicio donde tanto los legisladores como
el propio laso va a presentar su defensa
después de que la asamblea nacional
recordemos
aprobara el impeachment el pasado 9 de
mayo lazo es el primer mandatario que va
a político desde que se aprobara la
constitución en el año 2008 la solicitud
inicial de los legisladores opositores
para llevar a cabo este juicio político
fueron dos delitos concusión que es que
lasso abusó de su poder para recibir
dávidas para su lucro personal y
peculado que es malversación de fondos
públicos finalmente la corte
constitucional solo admitió a trámite el
delito de peculado Y es que según la
oposición lasso no finalizó un contrato
entre la empresa pública flota petrolera
ecuatoriana y la entidad privada
amazonas tankers para el transporte de
derivados del petróleo esto habría
constituido según la posición un delito
de peculado Aunque la oposición todavía
no ha mostrado las pruebas puede que hoy
empiece a mostrarlas cuando pues inicie
este juicio político lasso Eso sí
insiste en su plena inocencia y dice que
aquellos que quieren
juicio político solo buscan
desestabilizar la democracia y atentar
contra ella Marta eso en cuanto a lo que
dice la prensa en Ecuador pero qué dice
por ejemplo ABC news pues Andrés hay
bici news destaca la tensa relación que
hay entre la asamblea legislativa que
está capitalizada por la oposición por
el correísmo y el pachacútec que es el
brazo político del movimiento indígena
ecuatoriano y el gobierno no Ecuador
entre otras cosas viven estos momentos
además una grave crisis de seguridad con
una fuerte escalada de la violencia y
recuerda ABC news que es el segundo
intento de censura y destitución contra
lasso que ya hubo un intento el año
pasado que no prosperó por falta de
votos a favor el debate sobre el juicio
político podría extenderse hasta el
miércoles porque cada uno de los 137
diputados tiene opción de expresar sus
argumentos a favor o en contra y además
luego el lazo se aprenderá además
sostiene este artículo que tras todo
ello tendrá lugar la votación que podría
alargarse hasta el sábado bien Ahora
vamos a pasar a un medio regional vamos
a Colombia allí revista semana también
registro esta noticia que dice Marta
pues Andrés la revista semana describe
los posibles escenarios que se abren
para lasso a puertas de que inicie este
juicio político recordemos que para que
salga adelante el juicio político se
necesitan 92 votos de los 137 diputados
que componen el legislativo ecuatoriano
el primer escenario que se plantea para
lasso es que bueno pues se apruebe el
juicio político y lazo delegue el poder
en su vicepresidente actual que es
Alfredo borrero quien tendría que asumir
el final de la legislatura y presentar a
su vicepresidente ante el legislativo el
segundo escenario que plantea la revista
semana que puede ocurrir para Guillermo
lasso es que él mismo decrete la
conocida como muerte Cruzada que es la
disolución congreso y la convocatoria de
elecciones anticipadas y el tercer
escenario es que laso consiga los cerca
de 50 apoyos que necesita y Por tanto se
caiga el juicio político lo que pues
continuaría con esa tensión entre el
gobierno y la asamblea nacional y
nosotros por supuesto vamos a estar muy
pendientes de Cómo se desarrolla esta
noticia lo estaremos registrando a lo
largo de nuestros informativos Marta
vamos a cambiar de tema seguimos en el
Continente hoy el diario el País de
España pública una entrevista con Carlos
dada que él es el director del medio
salvadoreño el faro que pone de relieve
la persecución política que han sufrido
sus periodistas por denunciar las
acciones del gobierno de nayib bukele
una entrevista que se publicó un día
después de que el periódico de Guatemala
publicara su último número o el último
número de su edición diaria argumentando
también la persecución del gobierno de
Alejandro yamatei Pues sí Andrés malos
tiempos para la libertad de prensa en la
región centroamericana destacamos entre
esta entrevista del diario español el
país a Carlos uno de los periodistas más
reputados de América Latina y que dirige
el faro que es otro de los
medios Pioneros en la región y mejor
valorados el periodista destaca las
tensiones constantes que viven bajo el
gobierno de nayib bukele y dice que los
últimos tiempos han sufrido y han sido
Víctimas de espionaje propaganda
difamatoria acoso de Hacienda
señalamientos de todo tipo de delitos
esta entrevista deja algunos titulares
interesantes por ejemplo preguntados
sobre si la mano dura de bukele es el
antídoto para El Salvador dice
textualmente Carlos dada las pandillas
no bajaron de una nave espacial son la
expresión más violenta de una sociedad
podrida pero la desarticulación es una
foto del momento porque el estado
todavía no ha llenado el vacío que dejan
y preguntado por otra parte sobre las
dificultades que tiene ejercer el
periodismo hoy en día en El Salvador
dice Carlos dada que nunca antes había
sido tan complicado ante el acoso y la
persecución de un régimen que necesita
silenciarnos lo necesita porque una
parte fundamental de su estrategia es
imponer una sola narrativa eso dice
Carlos dada Marta y vamos a cerrar con
otra alarmante noticia y esta la publica
por ejemplo en distintas nacional y Es
sobre el aumento en las ejecuciones que
tienen que ver que se dan bajo la pena
de muerte sí Andrés un informe anual
preocupante en la amnistía dice que en
el último año 2022 ha habido 883 casos
de pena capital en 20 países Irán ha
sido el país que ha engordado estas
cifras con al menos 567 ejecuciones todo
ello Pues en el marco de las protestas
por la muerte de Maxi en septiembre del
año pasado por no llevar el velo bien
puesto las cifras de 2022 son las más
altas del último lustro y suponen un
crecimiento de más del 50% respecto a
2021 el informe no incluye ni a China ni
a Corea del Norte porque no emiten datos
oficiales dice que la mayoría de
ejecuciones se han dado en tres países
Irán Arabia Saudita y Egipto que
concentran el 90% de las ejecuciones en
cuarto lugar está Estados Unidos además
sostiene este análisis y este informe
anual que cinco países han reanudado en
el último año las ejecuciones judiciales
que son Afganistán Palestina Kuwait
myanmar y Singapur y otros como bahrein
comoras Corea del Sur lagos y níger
impusieron condenas a pena de muerte
tras un periodo de interrupción en
paralelo este informe de amnistía
también destaca algunos avances Y es que
en el último año 12 países han puesto
fin de manera total o parcial a la pena
de muerte una situación alarmante como
usted lo decía Marta Muchas gracias por
registrarnos lo que es lo que sucede hoy
en la prensa internacional Gracias
Andrés